this video is brought to you by raycon
[Music]
what's up guys michael here in case
you've been trapped in a weezer branded
snuggie since 2009 allow us to bring you
up to speed everyone is obsessed with
merch there's the mcdonald's chicken
nugget pillow there's a24 as film-themed
candles and logo and blaze and packing
tape there's merch for your favorite
radio station your favorite art museum
even your favorite fake girl boss hell
there's even merch that lets you loudly
and proudly identify as a salt
aficionado it hasn't always been this
way merch used to be something we bought
to remember that green day concert where
we almost made out with our crush almost
or it was that ugly slash depressing
swag thrust upon us by everyone from
citibank to the humane society but as
journalist adam bluestein observes in a
recent marker article people are now not
only willing to adorn themselves in
branded merch they actually go to great
lengths to seek it out and want to pay
for it so what explains the merch
revolution what does it mean when we
actively seek out a plate from our
favorite restaurant or shorts from our
favorite billionaire are we in heaven
hell or a swagified purgatory let's
bravely find out in this wisecrack
edition why everything is merch now but
before we get into it i want to talk
about today's sponsor raycon raycon
makes earbuds that lets you listen to
the sound of my voice or any other voice
whether you're at home or on the go i
mean that's what i use mine for
listening to wisecrack videos and
podcasts 24 7. whether you're cool like
me or whether you actually have other
interests like in music or movies you
can still enjoy raycon's 32-hour battery
life with eight hours of play time
that's enough time to watch space jam 2
4.17 times totally uninterrupted but if
you do get interrupted say by an
incoming phone call you can pick up with
the press of a button and chat with the
built-in mic raycon earbuds also
straight up look good as well especially
now that they have an improved rubber
oil look and they also feel good thanks
to optimized gel tips that ensure a
perfect fit another awesome thing about
raycons is that they start at half the
price of other premium audio brands but
you can't really tell the difference
well except for the happier state of
your bank account that is and speaking
of good vibes raycon's 45-day happiness
guarantee lets you make sure these
earbuds are totally right for you so
click the link in the description or go
to
com slash wisecrack to unlock exclusive
deals like up to 20 percent off your
recon order that's by raycon dot com
slash wisecrack to get a sweet deal on
some new earbuds and now back to the
show now for simplicity's sake we're
going to define merch as products often
shirts hats or tote bags that advertise
a brand or company which typically
doesn't make shirts hats or tote bags so
your capital g gucci belt not merge your
t-shirt proudly showing off your
favorite egg salad sandwich
totally merged and a real thing
on a basic level the concept of merch is
pretty simple it conveys taste whether
in film distributors makeup music and
even iced tea but for merch to fully
emerge as such a cornerstone of
contemporary consumption a few things
had to happen first off what constitutes
high status spending had to change
dramatically see for most of human
history producing consumer goods
required artisan handiwork and was thus
very expensive so it was easy for the
very wealthy to show off via luxurious
spending on items most people could
never dream of affording in early
pompeii that meant hiring an artist to
painstakingly craft a mosaic for your
wall in victorian england it's
hilariously meant displaying medicine in
your parlor to show you could afford to
see a doctor less wealthy people would
then find cheaper ways to copy rich
people's spending habits via shortcuts
like wallpaper or painting porcelain to
look like gold in 1899 economist and
sociologist thorstein veblen dubbed
these wealth-establishing purchases by
the leisure class conspicuous
consumption these were any goods
purchased in large part to convey high
socioeconomic status
now a lot has changed since 1899. the
second industrial revolution coupled
with increasingly sophisticated
manufacturing practices dramatically
decreased the cost of consumer goods
since then buying fancy hair ribbons or
leather-bound encyclopedias has become a
lot less expensive this made it
increasingly easy for less wealthy folks
to copy the consumption habits of the
uber wealthy they signaled aspirational
wealth through dress home decor and so
on nowadays in fact poor and
middle-class folks spend proportionately
much more on conspicuous consumption
than the wealthy do this poses a problem
as scholar elizabeth currie halcott
explains in her book the sum of small
things she asks if acquisition of
material goods is now fairly accessible
to all how do wealthy elites maintain
their status according to courage
hawkett the answer can be seen in the
rise of the aspirational class which has
effectively replaced the leisure class
the aspirational class is defined less
by wealth than by cultural capital like
knowing which ethiopian restaurant to go
to or which magazine to read as brand
strategist anna angelic writes in a
recent book the business of aspiration
modern aspiration is not about having
money to buy things but having the taste
to know what to buy that is to say
members of the aspirational class don't
choose to consume goods and services
based on what will make them look rich
rather they choose based on what
conforms to their taste which is largely
based on their values that's in part
because a lot of aspirational class
members aren't even rich in the first
place they're merely culturally savvy
they buy products based on what
sociologist pierre bordeaux called
objectified cultural capital i.e the way
certain objects accrue cultural and
symbolic value rather than simple
monetary value as curry hull could
elaborate the aspirational class finds
subtle symbols cultural capital and
language to distinguish itself from
other groups and if those subtle symbols
include an ironic dad hat all the better
but let's leave the aspirational class
aside for a second because innovation
and manufacturing also allowed for one
other big consumer shift the rise of
merch the core of the merch industry has
long been that classic printed t-shirt
cheap to make and typically cheap to buy
printed shirts were probably first used
for the 1939 film the wizard of oz in
the film workers in the emerald city
wear shirts that read oz as they restuff
the scarecrow printed shirts went
political in 1948 urging you to vote for
noted never president thomas e dewey who
who did not invent the dewey decimal
system that's when printing businesses
in miami started manufacturing screen
printed t-shirts and towels adorned with
popular vacation resorts logos we found
evidence of a similar racket in 1950
cincinnati one of those companies scored
the license for merchandising disney and
things would escalate but what really
changed the future of merch was
technology specifically innovations in
screen printing in the 60s couple that
with the youth cultural revolution and
merch was poised to explode as the
british rock invasion captivated the
hearts and ears of the youth buying
banned merch became a prime way to
express your hipness importantly printed
shirts also quickly became a major tool
of the counterculture to signal
alignment with protest groups and social
causes but merch wouldn't stay stuck in
the counterculture in the 1970s the hard
rock cafe and casino wondered what if
merch could become a bigger business
than our actual business they were
almost right merch now accounts for up
to 40 percent of their revenue this is
indicative of something else that was
also happening see throughout the 70s
and 80s increasingly cutthroat
competition among similar brands would
change marketing forever
suddenly brands had to start selling
consumers not on quality and or
innovation but on the brand itself as
researchers wrote for management
communication quarterly this was the
elevation of branding's importance as a
communication strategy in navigating a
crowded market in other words brands
became less about what they made and
more about who they were the easiest way
to be someone cool copy the
counterculture of course scholar paul
clements notes that marketers in the 80s
and 90s had grown up during the height
of the counterculture they savvily
copied that era's impression of
rebellion and revolt in their marketing
remember that final scene of mad men
[Music]
i'd like to buy the world a home in
post-draper years that also looked like
burger king declaring that sometimes you
gotta break the rules or toyota calling
her new supra revolutionary over the
following decades corporate branding and
with it corporate merch would continue
to pull from counter cultures to
maintain their cool image they'd
especially take inspiration from
skateboarding rap and internet
communities grabbing font styles and
other design elements in recent years
brands like makeup company glossier
would also start to borrow streetwear
brand supreme's marketing style they too
manufacture scarcity for popular merch
in order to generate hype and over the
past 10 years merge has become more
important than ever increasingly
infiltrating fashion and culture at
large this has been helped along again
by increasingly streamlined
manufacturing and distribution as well
as you guessed it the internet and these
days you don't have to be disney for
merch to be profitable the rise of micro
merch catering to niche markets now
sustains everyone from musicians to
podcasters to makeup influencers many
creators now supplement their incomes
with genuinely cool merch some of which
might even feature a certain monocle
wearing jackass during the pandemic
merch became especially vital for those
local bars restaurants and bookstores
with enough cachet to sell you on a cute
tank top branded weed grinder or a pair
of earrings shaped like a sandwich the
entangled phenomena of the value
obsessed aspirational class the
value-laden brand and of course cheap
manufacturing all converged to
facilitate the rise of merch as amanda
mall writes in the atlantic for decades
americans have been trained to see logos
and slogans as a primary means of
self-expression and even as a way of
telegraphing values and nothing does so
more clearly than merch but what is
merch really doing on a deeper level to
understand let's return to the
aspirational class the way we see it
merge has become a new kind of
conspicuous consumption rather than
showing off how wealthy you are though
it acts as a potent flex about your
cultural savviness and your values merge
is the natural culmination of
consumption as an expression of identity
and if that consumption happens to be
just a little bit ironic a la the kfc
crocs that sold out in 30 minutes well
that's all the better some of this is
the result of successful marketing over
the past decade as brand competition has
increased even more than it did in the
80s branding has increasingly shifted to
become more value oriented as angelic
writes brands shifted from increasing
value of their products through utility
competitive comparison and creative
advertising instead she explains they
focus on things like sustainability
artisanship and community in order to
give their products identity and
singularity you're not wearing a moon
juice shirt because it fits better
you're wearing it to show you value
wellness clean living and crystals
lighting up an a24 horror candle shows
that you value independent cinema even
if you like me are too scared to
actually watch mitsumar their cultural
potency can render merch even more
desirable than the real brand of
products themselves as bluestein notes
whether or not they are actually buying
your core product merge with a point of
view can resonate with people who are
somehow finding it to be a form of
self-expression merch in representing a
brand or artist cultural cachet confers
that same status onto the buyer people
are telegraphing their values and tastes
by associating themselves with jstor
over lexisnexis or with cash app over
venmo but to really understand why a new
yorker tote bag means so much to so many
people let's return to what brands as a
whole mean as media scholar adam
arvinson writes in his book brands
meaning in value and media culture
although brands have a long history as a
commercial institution reaching as far
back as the 18th century their position
as central components of the social
fabric was established in the 1980s as
we noted earlier this was around the
same time when branding became less
about the product and more about the
story or personality of the brand itself
the result was powerful as artwitsen
elaborates brands now became something
of an omnipresent tool by means of which
identity social relations and shared
experiences could be constructed the web
of modern brands thus helps establish a
common social world that we all inhabit
this happened at the same time as the
late 20th century collapse of community
amidst widespread urbanization
privatization of public spaces and so on
so you maybe used to identify largely as
a catholic or a dane or a new yorker but
the erosion of religious ethnic cultural
and other public communities also erodes
the significance of that identity as
angelic writes we are going through the
imagined community renaissance thanks to
modern brands stepping in as the social
constructs of belonging left vented by
traditional institutions she notes that
increasingly brands target communities
over customers merch is an obvious way
of telegraphing your membership to a
branded community whether via tote bag
or koozie and for the aspirational class
distinguish not by furs and jewels but
by their taste belonging to the right
branded communities is paramount
lighting a dinnertime candle in
victorian england meant you had access
to something rare and expensive today
sprinkling responsibly sourced spices on
your dinner isn't about conferring
wealth which few of us have anyway it's
more about living your tastes and values
it's not about prestige and exclusivity
but about identity and belonging to
certain taste communities and because
humans are very literal creatures we've
fixated on the most literal way to do
this buy a merch that spells out your
taste for everyone to see and this isn't
inherently sinister here at wisecrack we
love good merch in fact each of us owns
an estimated average of 1.75 grateful
dead t-shirts although i kind of skew
the curve on that um
but this one's i mean this one is like
colored and this one is like a whiter
thing this one has a totally different
font and it's from a different tour and
this one this one was limited edition
okay they're
they're all the same but we think it's
interesting that as young people's
economic opportunities become less and
less plentiful our consumption habits
are becoming increasingly important to
our identities as angelic notes unable
to succeed economically millennials are
turning their attention to everyday
things with an almost obsessive
laser-like focus it's why really liking
coffee or doing the right type of yoga
can almost constitute an entire
personality these days but what if our
obsession with taste and thus with cool
merch really has much more to do with
what we can't afford you know the little
things like houses cars advanced degrees
and quality medical care unable to
achieve the markers of success that our
parents and grandparents aspired to
we've found other ways to make our lives
feel richer and more meaningful and more
power to us for that but merch has
emerged as an easy and relatively
inexpensive way to accrue social capital
especially in a world where most of us
might never have you know
capital capital it's enough to make you
want to take a nice long hit from your
limited edition seth rogen sculpted pipe
but what do you guys think is the
popularity of merch a sinister indicator
of how much is wrong with our economy or
is it just a fun way to signal that you
too enjoy eating oreos let us know in
the comments big thanks to our patrons
for aligning yourself with the wisecrack
brand and be sure to check out our
podcast hit subscribe like it's the
checkout button on a supreme drop day
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you